greetings from podcast Ville its Monday
the 19th of September you bad
[ __ ] the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by CBD
Lyon calm listen everybody's talking
about CBD oil CBD is CBD that I got the
answer I got the answer CBD
Lyon calm tincture shad a vapor you name
it gummies the best [ __ ] raspberry
gummy you've ever had and you goddamn
lie 500 milligrams you'll sleep like a
baby recover you'll feel [ __ ] so good
you want to know what to do with
yourself go to CBD line right now look
at the third-party test results yourself
go to CBD line and on the way out press
in church and get 20% off your first
daughter delivered right the house the
church is also brought to you by upstart
most of us find the hard way getting
into debt is easy getting out of debt is
hard especially if your FICO score isn't
great thankfully now there's upstart
calm a revolutionary lending platform
that knows you're more than just a
credit score your upstart interest rate
is based on your education and your job
history
not your credit score so see why upstart
is ranked number one in that category
with over three hundred businesses on
Trustpilot
hurry the upstart calm slash shirts that
CH you are CH to find out how low your
upstart rate is checking your rate only
takes a few minutes and it will not
affect your credit that's upstart calm
slash Church kick this [ __ ] meal
leaves Monday the 19th of August get
your [ __ ] together make my hands estudio
how are you sir what's going on how long
look closer
get a little closer to me Harvey
Weinstein style that's how Harvey I
can't I can't hate you know he'd rub his
bump and shoulder on you did and it was
long downhill after that you know that
had done yeah so here I go again for
another three weeks so how long how long
has this to abengoa store
well we did about six seven weeks just
prior to this and then it been home for
about ten days
and it'll go back out for another three
come home for three go back out for
another 21 days or something like that
it's a little bit more this year because
the 40th anniversary it's the 40th
anniversary I love the release of hit me
with your best shot really such crimes a
patch for years crimes of passion won't
talk or not Jesus [ __ ] Christ can you
believe it well heat of the night was
before that right here I was there for
that
so my clone sleeps alone that's a good
house Aniki a little bit of a different
type of dark around yeah I heard she had
problems putting that album out like
somebody this that I still remember Pat
Benatar on the [ __ ] world catch a
rising star you do stand-up comedy
special with her I still love a Pat
Benatar on HBO did too special why from
Earth on HBO it was like a special and
then the biggest blunder I had was Pat
was gonna marry Neil that's right and
then TV to the contest she'd go to
Hawaii and go to the contest if you sent
in postcards so our plan was to go to
the wedding and [ __ ] tell Neal he
can't do it like you gotta take a hike
Neal yeah there's no way you're gonna
have a problem get the [ __ ] out of here
flight I'm not kidding I worked for a
bookie at the time sorry and I got off
work a lot on the 19th Street Minh and I
would go to a stationery store and I
actually every day for three weeks I
filled out cards and I would put a
hundred in the mail for more different
mailboxes when Louis City because first
prize is a trip to Hawaii second prize
is tropical tropical tropical like 100
copies autographed and the third prize
there you got a t-shirt there's some
[ __ ] don't all Sunday announced some
[ __ ] some [ __ ] mukatte wanted and
[ __ ] Virginia and then I'm waiting
for my album because I sent in a
thousand postcards no I'll go t-shirt
you got nothing I got dick yeah [ __ ] it
[ __ ] TV but that seriously they were
get married on MTV like that was how big
MTV was no stay oh yeah first video ever
played yeah second video second video it
was the first guitar player was he yeah
first guitar player so the first video
was video still the videos don't I'm not
sure what it was exactly but it well if
there was no they are what was the first
video player MTV yeah I think it's video
killed the radio star was one of those
type of jams is that right okay and then
Pat came up with either hit me with your
best shot or treat damn and the other
rascal song you were talking about last
night she had already money for nothing
well that was the first pin okay dang
straits
I'll bet 1987 you better run was no no
no the first song played on MTV came on
1981 September 15th of 1981 the first
song ever pile MTV was because you smell
like 10 [ __ ] who's I don't know oh
thank you dealing with video you know a
radio spot so what's the second song
played on you better run yeah you
[ __ ] go that and then it was also me
that we played last week that was so
much because they when MTV came on it's
not like they had a million videos no
they had 15 videos eight of them were
like oh like somebody had just done
promotional and they were terrible the
videos like the lead singer beat pop one
and the music would be gone off nothing
was friendís and nothing was psyched so
the only real videos you had was video
killed Iranian film which wasn't a band
it was like fishes and in my heart and
in my soul uh-uh-uh-uh-uh all that [ __ ]
yeah then it was path and then the other
high road chaining the video was Van
Halen if this is love live from Oakland
1981 which you played last week and you
could tell this
who the [ __ ] van Halen was oh yeah he
comes out with a bottle of Jack he puts
the [ __ ] scarf on he was anything am
i Oakland scarf and they go [ __ ]
crazy when you look at that you like
that's country roses without steroids
they were just opening up the door for
Guns and Roses on steroids a lot of
those bands were so what made you get
into this [ __ ] career you just gonna
add a rest around and Ohio no I wasn't
even references in the backdoor they
didn't exist either
you never saying I don't know what the
hell got me into this it kind of picked
me how old were you when you started
playing the ball I started I started
playing bass when I was about 13 but I
started on guitar about 10 11 you know
so I was I got an ax band right away and
my band opened up for I got a chance to
play with Ramsey Lewis I was a little
kid
and I thought that was really cool and I
was playing guitar and then nobody else
wanted to play bass the bass player quit
they said somebody's got to do it you
want to give it a try so my buddy lent
me a bass that was probably I don't know
$50 bass or something like that that he
got it wors and I just fell in love with
the instrument you know I started
listening to Led Zeppelin and
Steppenwolf and all these bands were
coming out and I just fell in love with
it you know it struck me when you were
18 what were you doing 18 at 18 I had
just gotten out of college I was 17 I
went to Kent State and I was still
playing in there all four years four
years I can't stay there and this is
after the disaster at Kent State
Legislators after yeah couple years
later yeah a little bit after not were
you in a band when you weren't at Kent I
was always in a band okay so we've been
this was all yeah this is all I've ever
done but my thing was on Wednesday I
would leave Kent State and I'd go play
gigs I'd go visit my friends in
Pittsburgh and then I would play gigs
Friday Saturday Sunday and then drive
back up to Kent State and then go to
school for three days was there any
money in those days about the same damn
money you're making a club now believe
it or not yeah it's about the same
[ __ ] crazy
yeah how crazy is this business you know
four years later yeah you know you get
the best guys in LA and come play for
it's because they want
play musicians have to play you have to
do comedy what made you make the jump
here well I knew if I was gonna stay in
Youngstown you know I was just gonna end
up playing clubs the rest of my life
probably not that we didn't have great
music but I love Youngstown hearts of
great I love Youngstown I think in there
yeah I think it's yeah well it's a great
time you can put a bet in anyway
yeah it's a better Church yeah yes you
aiming at the Browns $10 all right the
lines 13 you [ __ ] up yeah you can put
a better Youngstown is the gambling
capital of the [ __ ] world more action
goes to Youngstown Ohio than anywhere
else the [ __ ] country when you pull up
to a nightclub there's ninety nine cars
in the parking lot there's two people
sitting at the bar where do you think
everybody is yeah they're in the back
everybody's doing it and Youngstown's
with all of famous no that's in can't
can't I'm sorry the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame is including women where's the
football I can't okay yeah cuz
apparently that area is where football
started you know I think if I'm correct
the Detroit Lions where it started in
Youngstown Ohio that's somebody who told
me that yeah so that's why it's there
and then you came up how I yeah I got
you know i just wanted to lift it up i
did the college thing I followed my
mother's advice and did you know what
your major it industrial arts psychology
and just mildly in music you know I
wasn't really educated in music at that
point it was later on that you read
music and everything I do now because
when I came to LA I got my ass kicked
yeah I got my ass handed to me well he
would get on a session and I was a pair
of eyes I couldn't read this stuff you
know
some days you have to read fly [ __ ] some
days you don't have to read anything
it's whole notes but I just wasn't
competent at that and then I really
wanted to be a session guy because that
was very fashionable and I was getting
more into jazz I actually became a jazz
snob and that's all I wanted to play
until my friends opened up for foreigner
and I went down there the [ __ ] the
matter with me you know I don't want to
play rock and roll that's crazy that's
where I started so I dropped the jazz
singer and I didn't drop it but I
lowered
down and got way back into rock not when
you picked up the jazz bass did you have
a stand-up bass or the Julie no that
kind of came afterwards too you know I
really concentrated on the electric bass
and that was kind of my thing but then I
realized if I wanted to get more work
I'd better get into the upright so I
kind of took that up and study with some
people now for guys like me let's say
you went on the road with Led Zeppelin
hmm
would that be any situation for you to
put on a big stand-up bass would it make
a difference yeah in the sense in which
way yeah I would definitely make a dent
was dazed and confused be different
today oh my I am the bass a dazed and
confused would be amazing on upright
bass why well just just the nature of
the bass it has a different voice you
know electric bass has a very excuse me
it has a very focused kind of sound
where the the upright bass is more of a
bigger rounder sound a little bit warmer
tone any kind of fretless instrument is
going to speak differently than a
fretted instrument how will this
standing bass doing an arena though well
you know I mean with my kit yes like it
yeah uh-huh
mica just like anything else and it
translates if you got a great mixer it
can mix anything you know I would love
to see something like that some grab
bring gonna like the bass out the
[ __ ] oh they do it all the time they
do it routinely if you see Rod Stewart
you know if you see Barry Manilow if you
see any these guys that it's kind of
like a normal thing to have happen who
your rock influences my biggest
influence would definitely be John Paul
Jones so seriously John Paul Jones and
James Jamerson at the same time because
[ __ ] when I grew up that's the kind of
stuff that you could you know you had
that vast area to deal from you know to
pick from because those were the songs
that were on the radio so you could be
an R&B guy especially growing up in
Youngstown it was all about soul music
and you know that culture mixed in with
this rock that started to get introduced
into it you know and then a guy like
John Paul Jones he is an R&B bass player
in Iraq performance I think what there's
an arm B bass player I have an advantage
over
bass playing funky funky funky er yeah a
little bit more rhythmic probably listen
to ramble on okay a Zeppelin that's a
total James Jamerson bass line that's
amazing yeah it's really funky listen to
the brothers Johnson well we stand up
there were so nobody remembers the
brothers job I should do Louis Johnson's
bad sticky fingers and lightning licks
aside they call they still around no
Louis Bolton your past I'm not sure
Bullard passed but loses one of them was
at the Comedy Store one night years you
know 15 years ago was friends with the
door guy yeah and I was like I had your
album and all that because I transform
through the same thing I grew up in a
Cuban house yeah I saw stand-up bass
yeah and then I got into our beat I got
it I was into the fani all-stars no bad
stuff then and I have that Latin salsa
stuff like that he's antennae Bobby
Valentine oh yeah is his name is he's
interesting cuz he was really uh he was
a percussionist and turned him into a
bass player so I don't know something
weird
yeah and then I joined the band and they
said pick up the bass I don't know what
the [ __ ] I was doing so all we would do
is cover Beatles songs we basically
cover to help the whole out this is not
a stand-up bass at that point no this is
the [ __ ] thing and we got a hit we
had to get rid of the sing that cuz he
was a [ __ ] I still had I still had
the kid voice to Michael Jackson voice
back yeah racks okay so now I was the
bass player I got serious about it and
then what the pastoral music big-time
music store and you didn't see New
Jersey if you ever did the garden they
send you the past door to get all your
licks and I saw Greg Allman there when I
was a kid yeah yeah wall just hanging
out he was there with Cher that's how
young I was
I was why they I was walking like so I
was like Jesus nothing right yeah like
and I took bass plant I'm like the third
floor but the band broke up so for a
year I took bass lessons it's pretty
much reading music a stuff but then
there was no band to pick me out like I
knew different things but it was like I
don't even know how to get into a bad
basketball came I think I ate somebody's
[ __ ] and the dream look we made a nice
play I went down that was it I was there
I didn't know you play I I couldn't tell
you what I was doing
oh my god it was like a year no yeah he
would go up there the guy was a good guy
yeah he let me play along to music and
I'd bring like her too and fire and the
early stuff that's the way of the world
cuz I liked all Verdine white as bad as
swamped I like the fungus Johnson I
liked there was just so many there's
something about the bass that you don't
know it's good
do you listening to it like you know
that's very true there was something I
was listening to the other day in the
car I'm like listen to that [ __ ] bass
line
yeah I love for it's American band or oh
grandma American woman one of those two
probably American band will go there you
go that's American woman just tremendous
[ __ ] yeah the ear doesn't really usually
go to I usually go to the bass you go to
the bass I love the lead guitarist when
I go to the bass
well lead guitar always tends to take
prominence right but do yourself a favor
go listen to a Beatles record from the
other room and let the bass come through
the wall where it takes out all that top
end stuff and you're listening to the
bass listen to the voice of that and all
the different baselines and how melodic
McCartney place that's the best way to
listen to the Beatle record really oh
yeah it's fantastic was McCarthy that
good of a bass player amazing his parts
he's not the chops guy he's not like
Stanley Clarke or chakra Pistorius but
the parts that he came up with her just
beautiful I liked him more with the
wings you liked him with wings yeah I
liked his bass more with the wings that
I heard it with the Beatles with the
Beatles it was very generic his base
with wingless I think he picked it up a
little bit he had to play louder because
his wife sang badly do you remember
there was that you remember when they
took away the music yeah his wife's me
and it was just horrible they would kind
of throw thunder at her and they were
breaking light behind it which is where
is Hiroko
that's a tosser yeah that's probably on
par right no I like if you went through
in our common American thing like a
fifty year old I grew up in between the
wings and the Beatles and you said
listen you got a one gun one bullet I
think and I've had with you Yoko I've
never met a Yoko Ono fan and I feel
horrible they blame her for the Beatles
they blame her for bad music yeah they
blame her for putting them eluc on
[ __ ] John Lennon she was walking
behind them everybody knows if you
Chinese you gotta walk in front of me
don't walk behind me [ __ ] that's bad
luck you even go to a blackjack table
ten thousand or something you lose and
look behind you there's always a smiling
Chinese guy thinking it's the year the
dragon meanwhile you're going through
your [ __ ] lungs if she would have
been walking behind them let me shoot we
got shot but [ __ ] isn't that the
nature of the everybody hates Yoko and
the kid she's got he's second on the
list the Shan no not the one that did
the cokehead that came out after his
remember the one came out from the Lost
Diaries Oh like once he died one came up
that was his twin yeah I'm sitting here
by the river and he sounded like him and
then he started smoking long and Coppola
tour got cancelled now there's that one
then there's the one that looks like a
white family adopted like he's one of
those Chinese looking kids like a white
family adopt him they gave him a nice
egg you know the Chinese guy is sixteen
Candles kind of white what was it was a
Chinese guys sixteen Candles what's his
name Colin and they will always hit the
thumb anytime they say is they well
that's a whole different deal man okay
yeah anyone to that one I mean yeah
there you go
yeah Gary one thumb Abby oh my god
you're totally on it man you look up
everything he's the man he's great
so we've had a few bass players on we've
had a Rudy we've had yes and Cyn come on
and they've all said something similar
what you said that like it's almost like
music was a part of them yeah so like so
with Joey like I played violin for a
year in fourth grade
talk about no no don't tell that to
nobody I know it's embarrassing but like
do you do you think you can is music
something you can teach to people or do
you think it's just something that
you're born with and you find yeah you
can teach it you actually can teach it
uh I like to go teach at grade schools
and stuff like that I teach these kids
first second grade you know teach them
the scales but can they be like pros
like you could they like not everybody
can do that I think you have to have a
certain aptitude every [ __ ] days
there's a kid on online playing tool has
a half-black kid playing [ __ ]
something do you I'll tell you one
there's a kid how I made money was I get
conga drums yeah I put him in my mom's
bar and I play conga drums to Spanish
music learn how to play the conga
gentleman people go you know the kids
got in here right a little bit I find
out my uncle he's from Glendale you know
my mother's brother uh-huh and then he
had a band he opens up Eartha Kitt but
they opened up for the stones in 70
something that's crazy so he played the
cops in your blood man then my cousin is
in Cuba now have the national touring
band she just was that South by
Southwest yeah at an article about her
in time but she's coming she's about
that she's got a default whatever they
[ __ ] call it yeah
she's got to come over because she's
about to bust the bank here yeah but I I
always have the attitude towards music
mmm one of the scariest things in my
world is the guitar how so I know if I
pick up a guitar everything else will
fall to the wayside in your life yes I
love the get you'll get consumed with it
I'll get overly console really concerned
I have a very addictive personality and
that's something that I've been wanting
to do it's like being 13 and knowing you
want to eat a chick's [ __ ] you just
gotta find the chick to let you I'm when
you were third to you like I can't wait
thing somebody's [ __ ] maybe the baby
show you stuff a lot you start looking
at your aunt's friend and [ __ ] like
that's that nothing is sacred that sound
nothing you know I've always wanted to
learn how to play like David Gilmour I
buy the damn thing get it always oh they
have a starter kit at Guitar Center and
Gilmore
my example Gilmore I'm a Gilmore guy
Jimmy Page and then I gotta throw around
throwing that yeah you know I've always
loved Neal his guitar solo on precious
time his guitar I think we want to Pat
Benatar's best songs is I'm gonna follow
you yeah that's that kind of house
that's killer the other side the flip
side they had a video of and walked in
the streets late at night his guitar
work is sensational so many things about
run between the raindrops oh my god
that's the best that's my favorite
guitar solo the leanest he's done some
work and I don't think people have a
looked at Neal like that
well she's a chick band what's Neal know
Neal to rip your thong Liza he's really
replace Randy Rhoads on Sabbath without
batting a [ __ ] and I learned all his
stuff and done it Neal had it in the met
that night that's why he wasn't Aaron
just because he yeah killer killer
guitar player and his solos are part of
the composition you know they're not
just different every night they're part
of the song when you hear Jesse's girl
you know immediately it's him you know
and it sounds like Neil Giraldo all the
time you know what's one song Lily hates
everyone it's a lost Mike them what ass
into something and I put on hours for
children huh and his guitar work yeah
and the hell is for children is second
to none I had a whole dot not pal pal
downtown Holly underlines everything
it's just [ __ ] brilliant now how long
you out here in LA kicking it before
something happens before we leave no
before something happened in your life
Oh music or something yeah what the dick
Rose finally I came out here in 77 and
oddly enough I left
Youngstown the same time that Myron
Grumbach er did cuz he and I were
playing in a band in Pittsburgh
get the [ __ ] guys I grew up with Myron I
had a friend called Otto every time he'd
do a C look like my Robert jumping
around on the trolley he would lose I'm
not [ __ ] you want to be Myron he was a
client still around yeah he's still
around as he's touring no he's not
playing right now I mean he might be
doing stuff in town here but he's not as
a play with us we had the anniversary
30th anniversary tour and he played with
us
okay but he decided to take a break from
the road and yeah but he and I were you
know grew up in Youngstown we left the
same time he went to New York I said I'm
not going there
it's cold weather I want to go out to LA
or making a bunch of records out there
I'm gonna join I don't know the Eagles
Led Zeppelin whoever they all think I
could fall in with you know had all
these high aspirations so I came out
here and I kicked around for a long time
and then I started going hanging out at
dick Gross School of Music and started
playing in the faculty fusion band so
dick became my friend he says you know
let me give you an education here come
in you know and learn so I did and it
was composition and arranging because I
had a certain amount of facility on the
base but then I got really serious about
studying the bass and practicing 12
hours a day and stuff like that I
started getting better gigs and what was
like your first big cake
my first big gig well the first time I
went out for on the road for a little
while was with Lisa Hartman no [ __ ] Lisa
Hartman it was a great band you know
Carmen Grillo's in it Jack White was
bland drumsticks prick together yeah
Phil chanel was in it
sterling Smith was in it yeah it was a
really good band you know how old you
know I'm not now at this time oh well
okay Jack [ __ ] white you know like
under 13 now no but let's yeah I don't
know I guess it was about 2300 Jack not
gonna white oh yeah like how do you act
well we just took it for granted you
know I mean [ __ ] boy he wasn't doing
anything yet either you know we were
just like up-and-coming okay I don't
know who's Jack white oh no oh this is
not the Jack White the artist Jack well
this is the drummer Jeff okay okay
same name but different drummer and so
all of us were just coming up and you
know we're just starting to get gigs and
get better ones and stuff like that you
just keep working your way up the ladder
and stay dedicated you're not gonna get
it unless you just friggin focus on it
man what year is this this is 78 of
where you hang in
in those days well there was many places
to hang there was Josefina's anybody
could walk in there al jarreau used to
walk in got his crazy stuff
there was remember the sold out well you
were not here then the sold out was like
a soul club down on Sunset had great
music of course the troubadour you know
Tom Waits used to hang out there all the
time you know when I first got here was
crazy about 1978-79 I got in this fusion
band called the Boone Durbin and we
played at the troubadour and it was like
high energy fusion stuff and we were the
first band to actually have a spotlight
there except for Elton John you know
this this was music that used to keep me
up at night because it was taxing [ __ ] I
never played a Samba in my life I'm from
Youngstown Ohio what do I know about a
Samba but I had to learn all this
high-energy stuff and that's what kind
of fueled me into you know becoming
educated and branching out and spread my
wings a little bit some people have a
certain aptitude this young man I mean
from the day he came out of the womb he
would sit down and play the drums it
would play with sticks on a briefcase
with the cartoons that he was watching
so he's about not even 2 years old and
he's starting to drum so I just knew he
was a natural-born drummer is he
drumming that fantastic drummer
tremendous saying if he sucked I would
say that too but he's the creek charmer
you know a time of the Rogan podcast one
day we're talking about music yeah but
all these drummers make oh [ __ ] he's all
yeah this is a guy named Terry Bozzio
that oh he's all that [ __ ] lunch
people a who and that night I got home
and the guy some hit kid hit me up he's
like that's my [ __ ] father oh yeah we
put him on the podcast we just talked
that Terry's kid that was when we did
the hacen he went to outer space yeah oh
man type up Liam out of space you'll see
Bozzio playing the drums over oh he's so
funny I love those you know I love all
that [ __ ] Yeah right like what I missed
emotional you missed me you're mr. pizza
if it's the big love mine I don't make a
fine piece of the bagels I miss yes I
missed a garden
and I missed the Nassau Coliseum when I
missed the Meadowlands which was 20
minutes from my house yeah that's not
what I miss I miss when Nick calls me
and says hey dude doing anything tonight
there's a little dive bar called the
mint over on 78th on Third Avenue that's
gonna be down there to live with Mick
I think slash is going down there yeah
and you would catch these impromptu
little $15.00 and you'd sit there like I
remember being at the Village Gate yeah
20 years ago don't stand up and as I was
walking up Eric Clapton was walking in
and I'm like that's the show 1993 I'm
like why are you doing it yeah it was
nice to meet you too I shook his hand
and I saw how cool was that my god and
then I was going on audition one day and
he was at the light on Hollywood you
know Santa Monica and like vine I was
walking across the street to an audition
yes and I saw he was Eric Clapton let go
knock and he's like not right now
Village Gate 1993 and he goes are you
doing you got his attention and he
remembered yeah remembered you know
you're right that's what I like yeah
forget about anybody you go see a
[ __ ] show right I want what make
called me knows this I'm gonna gather
with some guys come on whether it's a
ten dollar cover ya know the bartender
and you go there and all send Charlie
watch for coming and we playing the
piano or Stanley Clarke coming and join
you right that's what I miss I missed
that height that's hard to find that
that's money that's once-in-a-lifetime I
was standing and I just got done playing
a gig with the fifth dimension and I was
in Memphis and I went to BB King what
year was this
oh this had to be probably 89 something
like now this is the fifth dimension up
up and away I'm gonna went great some
I'm beautiful well there's a fun gig so
how do you go from playing that the
better thought well we'll get that lace
it's you're playing the same notes you
you want to do you want to play for this
song okay Jim Webb songs are probably
some of the best songs you'll play in
your life Burt Bacharach songs every
time I played one less Bell I would get
the chills Ray's coming in next week is
that right ah
his violinist the violence she oh she
was right around the corner yeah really
and she's on tour with burnt or the
other guy see the Bert or Paul like Oh
Polly she's evil he's working all of ya
she's with ankus cancer seed or their
inner I see her tweets and I'm like oh
you know she's out of [ __ ] beaters
Yankton and you know so I guess she
opens up for both of ya goes from the
back Burt Bacharach and you know Paul
Anka who didn't he write a song for
Jesus
didn't he tell cut your hair you'll do a
lot better he had a thousand authorities
like that
he told what's-his-name to cut his hair
next day we got became out in John and
something like yeah those guys oh yeah
it was definitely a heavy influence yeah
he's a heavy influence yeah oh I was
gonna tell you the story about I'm
standing there in the club and who comes
in but the stones Bobby Keys Charlie
Watts Woody and Keith Richards they're
all on stage all of a sudden they're on
stage Jagger wasn't there but they're
just jamming on songs I mean to have
that happen to you and out of nowhere
was just amazing and where was this this
was at BB King's and Memphis okay
everything I heard did that bit all that
great right they just walked in they
were onstage in a minute I mean I was
getting chills it was just great and
what were they playing oh they were just
jamming jam yeah they were jamming no
specific song or anything like that but
you know it was four fifths of the
stones man no what year was that that
was probably about I'm thinking early
90s late eighties well they still
recorded down there and Alabama didn't
do it much work down there the day I
don't know how much what's in that
studio I must I'll show them what social
I think it was mobile I think Muscle
Shoals was prior to that prior that goes
back a minute I think yeah they came
over I think was when early on before
they had their work visas or some yeah
they used to have to just go to Muscle
Shoals or one have enough money to some
to buy a zz something crazy like
couldn't buy to get away you're kicking
it around I'm kicking it around for a
long time and you know just starting to
get better gigs little stuff like that
and you know then you start getting
into the more touring Szechenyi kind of
guy and but at that time there was so
much work I mean there was casual work
you know what they call casuals you know
what they are they're just like gigs
that you go do and put guys together you
just show up and you all play the songs
cuz you know bunch of songs and that's
what they are but then I started getting
more serious about it and really aiming
for the session thing and you know
trying to get on tours because there's a
sideman you could make great money at
that point not like it is today it's you
know like everything is us the budgets
have gone down so you don't make the
same kind of dough but yeah it was just
an interesting time there was so much
music going on and you could just work
your ass off you know I would do 60 gigs
in December you know and what a special
mark this well session work live work
live you know yeah so there was a lot of
work back then and I started getting
more into the touring thing and then I
got that got the call that it was funny
right after the earthquake I was on my
hands and knees 94 in 94 yeah I'm on the
kitchen floor repairing my floor because
it was damaged from the earthquake and
the phone rings and it's Neil Giraldo
and I was back in the days of call
waiting so I get a call says excuse me
one second can you hold on and I got a
call to go out with Jethro Tull at the
same time you know so I go from no work
to two really good offers and my wife at
the time was pregnant was this young man
I thought well you know the family thing
is probably a better situation for me
and the Ohio connection cuz Myron was
still in the band Neil's from Parma Ohio
and I said you know that that looks
really attractive to me so uh why not
did the audition like I think three
times and then it comes time to meet Pat
in she walks in she goes let me see your
socks so I sure my white socks because
you're from Ohio you're in the band
that was my audition what was your
connection to Jethro Tull at that time
how did you get out don't marry don't
marry it was the drummer at the time I
know friends
I was friend that's the advantage of
just doing session work yeah just
getting tired
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba yeah how I hadn't
met kneeled before that I only met Neil
one time there
was the club in the valley that I'll
pelicans retreat used to have great
music got there so that was quite a
musicians hang in Calabasas
so I met Neil because you know Myron's
association with me and stuff so I had
met him before but they really wanted a
girl because they wanted a real high
vocal and stuff and they ended up with
me what happened to Roger Katz he's
around what's he doing he's playing bass
in bands yeah he just keeps in touch
over pad or whatever well I think they
just had sort of a changing in the guard
cuz they had you know a few bass players
after that's a New York session he kind
of guys you know came into the band for
a while Fernando Saunders and he was Lou
Reed's guy and you know so they had some
different players for a while and then
when they wanted to come back I guess I
kind of got in the mix and that's how I
ended up being here that's 25 years ago
I'm Leon somebody don't put it probably
about six no [ __ ]
yeah what a job to get yeah yeah
especially in this day and age where
it's not a lot of music is coming out
mainstream yes all these older bands are
just raking it up you know you've got to
be an alleged act if you want to work
seven nights it's out there they have
the style Jack's bands and you know a
couple years ago I hosted it the
Hollywood Bowl for like groove is in the
heart I don't even know the [ __ ] it was
it was like four disco band saw some
[ __ ] yeah this is that'd be 15 years ago
and I was like wow look at all these
people yeah I thought oh broke up and
shoot my Broken Arrow from my heart okay
whatever they were [ __ ] called it was
like them the chick who sang if I can't
saying you if I can't have you I don't
want no but yeah we say name Jesus did
go-go's the go-go's yes the go-go's and
I went down there a little cute chick
from the Gogol's he's there and walked
up with her and I remember dawn wouldn't
[ __ ] someone come see the girl go yeah
it was packed it's not believable it was
bad we've toured with them and I had kid
here and didn't play was telling me that
he goes on those soul things its grease
on was a piece yeah
and that's WV they only had three songs
anyway right that's all you need
I just did that in January what did you
do oh she's
do blue magic shy lights I thought you
had the shy lights on your resume so
yeah keep em missing on us oh yeah I did
quite a bit with Keith that was a lot of
fun doing these days
Keith passed away did he really ask he's
been gone you know what kills me about
Emerson Lake and Palmer that I don't
judge a man's by his money I don't judge
a man by what he drives I don't judge a
man if he beats his woman I don't give a
[ __ ] I looked through your record
collection and when I was a kid if you
didn't have brain salad surgery
you gave the cup of coffee or whatever
back to the mother yeah thank you mama
give me that and you're told to go for
you gotta have legs up one - you got you
had a half there was sir nouns Aqualung
yeah double lifeguards Oh like you had
to have the Beatles that's not
everything before [ __ ] made they
didn't smoke dope when they were walking
around like the 12 commandments I don't
want those Beatles I want the ones after
they met the Hindu tomorrow I'll never
come Raul never knows and all that you
know like that was nothing no no throw
them for the deeper [ __ ] the deeper [ __ ]
that's that's what I really yeah that's
what you go for that's what I really
[ __ ] go for well there's a lot of
great stuff out there I mean my first
concert was James Brown how good was he
oh I so stupid good I'm still with my
white girlfriend and we're the only two
white people in the audience but was my
first concert my mom had a drive us
there I was so young but from that segue
into all this great rock music and Wes
and we create rock bands and in Ohio I
mean you know that the human beings and
a lot of great bands local talent glass
heart and stuff like Chrissy Hynde
yeah she's from Alliance yeah yeah I saw
her she did like four shows in New York
you know in the 80s you just didn't go
to New York you went to the garden you
were there yeah so you did too at the
garden one of the metal lands one at the
Coliseum and then the summertime they
had that Beach place Jones Beach Jones
Beach every time you play there ran it
right always right she broke her leg she
did whoa she broke her leg on Saturday
they cancel with show on August 4th
which was like a Monday yeah and Tuesday
and every scheduled the show that [ __ ]
came out with crutches and did it took
the crutches the room into the audience
and so let's [ __ ] do that people
would kill themselves like that's uh
that was 84 that was though oh no no no
no no no oh yeah yeah not even the
perfect stranger all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
tremendous tenders were I was at that
show the drummer was I had seen them
earlier in a smaller joint and he would
do [ __ ] with his drumsticks he would
pointer here and hit the drum the
sticker company you catch it out of the
air and [ __ ] I'm crazy you know it's
it's changed so much of my shant's crazy
man but after I started talking I
started watching her performances and
you you know from this last tour there's
a couple people who did you know Puerto
Rican cassettes that's not like [ __ ]
a normal camera guy like some chubby
chicky they're gonna be here eating the
corn and [ __ ] yeah back to Champa I
love this song
what was the last album you put out with
Pat I think our last record well we've
done a couple live ones so it's not all
been studios okay the last one that we
did summer vacation was I forget what
year it was and we did go that was
around 2001 and we've had some releases
you know like access video releases and
things like that but we haven't really
done a proper studio record for a long
time you know how do you feel I don't
feel about the Benatar situation by your
life about my life I
man I'm blessed oh you kid I got two
great kids and you know I get to play
music for a living
I've kind of segue not out of music into
pizza but Pizza gives me a lot of
satisfaction you know it's it's a fun
factor that doesn't exist in a lot of a
lot of places you know it's pretty pizza
people are fun man they like that
parties they like to rock they're like
rock stars this guy that I study with
Tony Gemignani
I call him the Jimi Hendrix of pizza
I used to call him Mick Jagger but that
that's a little old for him because he's
a young guy but the guy is just like
non-stop and he's the best pizza all in
the world if you like his style pizzas
yeah so he's done a lot for me you know
it's I I feel blessed to be able to have
these two careers to bounce around back
and forth
of course it drives you know that's
because you're busy all the time you're
always taking up and consumed with
something and my kids are getting older
now so I don't have to do as much
childish I once did but beyond blessed
man and I'm still alive that's that shy
you you know you were before the show we
were talking about we were saying about
wills and stuff like that for people to
understand when you hit 50 you get hit
with a dose harder reality the first
guess you did I got the label you block
the candles happy birthday yeah you're
50 and I thought you know you start
going you know what I'm on the other
side yeah I've got a lot more behind yet
than you do it right have a lot behind
me and life becomes a little different
you look at it through a one-eyed
telescope now you know well I'm my big
pet peeves in life is my time I can't
believe how I've changed my time the
last 15 years you before mercy I think
once I stopped doing the drugs my time
really became valuable to me something
that I had no concept of when I was 21
because when you're 21 you can another
time the world but you know what you
really [ __ ] don't you really [ __ ]
don't know it's a surprise it's a
[ __ ] surprise and you're like you
know what I ain't coming on that how
they ought to be a bacon next year and
that [ __ ] doesn't come you get into
waterfall and now you got a [ __ ] hump
you're a leg and now you can't be a
break then I gotta be a [ __ ] singing
opera you know it's just you appreciate
time you know people call you up me like
hi I'm not having a party for my 40th
birthday in Santa Monica we gonna spend
it by yourself [ __ ]
cuz I ain't got an hour to drive down an
hour back with your creepy little
[ __ ] friends to sit around with
I wish you you know you gotta throw
yourself a birthday party get the [ __ ]
out of here
check please I so I gotta go you look at
your time and you you we begin you know
you said it yourself I mean you know you
tell your son the pizza parlor when you
kak coz it becomes a reality
yeah you know I love to give my wife a
stab in the morning I can't no more
because the highest time I got a heart
attack is between 5:30 in the morning at
lunchtime I stick to those statistics is
that right
the high after you turn 50 yeah the most
vulnerable you are to a heart attack is
between 5:30 in the morning and
lunchtime
that's why I don't go jumping up and
down on a google call you help me with
this bureau [ __ ] you say I'll see you at
12:15 I get on the earthquake zones and
I'm out come help me lift it you're
lifting yourself
call the [ __ ] on it I've got a Home
Depot there's two guys there for the
small 50 and of the pizza from Palmer
that help you out but it's so weird how
you start looking at those things and ya
go Bob absolutely and I know lift
weights at 10:00 every [ __ ] weights
but you start looking at those things
you you know well my mother died it was
a party my mother died there we have a
half a million dollar account waiting
for you one of my mother died nothing
there was nothing there was no will yeah
which meant my father got the money and
he was my stepfather he got everything
you know so I learned about life too
hard right yeah yeah nothing to me out
of the house that was it no so sure
because she didn't work on the real name
she worked over there an alias you
would've drove Trump crazy I think
everything drives me yeah you don't
worry about uh you know you have to
start thinking about your kids you have
to and you have to leave them a certain
knowledge not to fall apart that's why
you bring it up right because they dog
it's like this you can just get off the
phone
well you do nothing I'm over here I just
had it [ __ ] the sausage is giving me
heartburn
yeah guys take a [ __ ] and I'll call you
next thing you know there's an ambulance
at your dad's house god forbid the
sausage was a little heart attack cuz
that happening my buddy my Maserati
called ya know what to call him back his
wife is gone answers
he died he must have called you five
minutes before he had a heart attack in
the bathroom
you don't take nobody for granted no
look at your kids when my story well I
think of my story that's why I write
something like Sons of Anarchy I write
something for my daughter every day in
that notebook so if something happens to
me before you tell her that I took your
baseball and sold it for two eight balls
she's gonna read about it first
she's gonna know and I told you about
that I stole his two bass guitars yeah
hoping for an eighth book he's mine I
got a half ounce of coke it's one of the
eight ball you know no but I'm just
saying that we speak like this we really
like so you guys a you and I are [ __ ]
super fortunate to even be walking
around hundred musicians do you know all
that are gone that you went never mind
God that did one too many hits of coke
one too many drumsticks to the head yeah
and now they're walking around like
Steven Adler oh yeah there's a lot Dez
Trish and Raiders has a lot more of
those guys than what there is guys like
you found 50s successful I'm these not
Led Zeppelin with a [ __ ] plane yeah I
don't have that kind of gonna shark up
some chicks [ __ ] that's your work yeah
what's up let's tuck a shark up some
chicks Yeah right a little baby shell Oh
baby shirt all right now first probably
a dildo right the dark now as it stands
two of the guys in Led Zeppelin would
have been thrown in jail today oh
there's a rumor that that it's
well-known Jimmy Page travel with a 16
year old on the road years four years 16
yeah and somebody I think Bono's bought
bonds Oh gonzo bond drama had another
issue also he likes little [ __ ] girls
that we uh that was looked over when you
in fact if you read key through it
that's why it's so weird that you guys
did live albums because if you read the
Keith Richards book one chapters divided
- what happened to the live album and
show we know in the seventies everybody
had a live out
it started with Peter Frampton jerks and
Lizzy Frampton
live in Yucatan what's the what was a
cheap trick live in Buda Kyle Jesus yeah
man everybody wanted to go to [ __ ]
Japan Judas Priest
at least at least everybody was
releasing these live albums and all of a
sudden you see Rihanna really sing live
on good luck
you see [ __ ] Britney Spears releasing
a live up cuz you got to do it you can't
fix it they said they forgot that the
industry got so technical that they
forgot how to how to wire a drum that's
why I asked you about the bass yeah are
there still people that you know bring
out a big bass yeah UK that well
technology is your friend as well I mean
you know drum machines and things like
that I used to hate him in the 90s
because bass players were losing all
kinds of work to synthesizers and
drummers were losing the work to the
drum machine but they're a tool for you
to use that you can blend them into your
music and they can help you in a lot of
ways but it doesn't it shouldn't mean
the demise of performance and learning
how to play there's no stop you are good
also because the John Paul Jones no I
wish I had my mind always say I wish you
would take piano lessons why don't you
play the organ when you do this I don't
mind I just want to play the guitar I
want to be in the Beatles I want to be
in that you know I want to do that so I
wish now that I would have that
knowledge but you know when he's doing
no quarter at the gun oh man and he's
playing the synthesized yeah that's
doing the base and you're looking at him
with his little bo-peep haircut because
he had that [ __ ] up little bo-peep I
could there's a we all had some weird
dude oh my god when you look at those
album covers you know one thing about me
is this is the same do I had in 78 yeah
I've never changed hairdos this is it
gel pull my back and that's it that's a
good way to go that's it I never had
time to spikes yeah and then I would
punk rock this this is it my hairstyle
has not changed since day one once it's
a damn shag went out that was yeah for
me just like a half of fact I was 13 I
had the line of them over here like Dick
Van Dyke oh yeah but big van Dijk wasn't
getting [ __ ]
he probably is now he's 100 he needs 22
my egg was that poor bastard hey I
didn't tell you Led Zeppelin was my
second concert really yeah where James
were a Cleveland Public Hall what did
you think what year I was what year was
no way that was must have been 69
probably so only the first record was
out they opened up with the immigrant
song and I never heard it and there I am
at a big concert you know I'm a young
kid and I had a camera and I was shaking
like a leaf you know I was standing in
front of the stage in here I'm here and
all this [ __ ] and man it just killed me
I was just so blown away $6.50 6.50 who
opens hood
nobody but nobody knows nobody did I
don't think they had an opening act at
that point I think it was just them so
now you torn you do the music
yeah torn doing it one day you say you
know what I'm gonna open up a pizza Paul
well I was love pizza you know growing
up in Youngstown as a pizza parlor and I
recorded cool and it's all good you know
you know yeah that's tough talk about
column on you know alikum Green has the
best column mother I've ever had but
anyway it was just a great way to grow
up and all the pizza was was great I
loved it I loved the whole Sicilian
tradition because my father passed when
I was young and now it's the Irish side
of me but I didn't really know that side
as much as I did the Sicilian side so
pizza was part of the deal you know
sunday gravy at Grandma's and all that
so I always had this romantic thing
going with pizza I loved it and then as
I started a tour you'd get some [ __ ]
pizza and then you get some really great
stuff and we call it bus lobster because
it shows up far too often and you know
so I just started to think about it and
then I what I found out through
investigation was there was so much cool
stuff going on out there
that I started to go to the pizza Expo
and really get into it and become
familiar with the guys that were the top
dogs that's kind of what precipitated
this and then you know part
of getting older as we said before as
you think in terms of a little bit more
longevity and a legacy and it you know
I'm probably not going to be as popular
as you know Mick Jagger in this lifetime
so what am I going to leave for my kids
and so it just kind of all melded
together and I got interested in it and
started doing it and then the boys are
in it so it's just like a shoe-in and
who did you get the help you teach how
to make the beat the pizza I studied a
lot what the guide Tony Gemignani I told
you about learned a lot from him but
I've gone everywhere I've studied with
the Hunt Brothers who teach the
Detroit's down not necessarily teach
these guys are not all necessarily
instructors but they all have a great
amount of knowledge michael--ah mark in
Cleveland Ohio great pizzaiola there's
just a ton of them so I would go study
with these guys because I'd meet them
all on the road many studies you would
go with them and make a few pizzas yeah
well I go to their pleasure I'll go to
their place for a couple days and if
they'll have me
I'll stand around and watch em make
pizza so I just kept going what style
are you going for right now who all this
family well that's our thing we're into
a multiple style thing so we do Sicilian
New York Ohio Detroit Neapolitan so
we're into this multiple style thing and
I thought I invented it so I'm looking
around nobody's doing this because
everybody wants the pizza that they grew
up on it's the best frigging beats on
the planet so I thought I was going to
do that and invent it and then I found
this guy Tony and I approached him and
said hey man you stole my idea and we
became friends because of that and so I
meant to the multiple stuff is Detroit
good I haven't I haven't tried by people
to tell me about it recently it's like a
like a thick kind of like crispy sort of
yeah it's cool I've never had it's
amazing because it's you know it's a
medium thick crust but it's got this
caramelized cheddar cheese it comes down
the sides and just like a toasted cheese
sandwich and then you got the mozzarella
in the middle and then the racing
stripes of the sauce and everything and
then of course your toppings but man
it's just a great stouts light
it's not heavy like you think it's gonna
be a big heavy pizza Sicilian can be who
can possibly be but it's not a weight
it's not because it's not bad if it's
made properly it's highly digestible
food and it's not like a sinker in your
stomach that's why we need this cheap
stuff you're gonna feel like [ __ ] when
you eat better pizza
it's prepared properly you're gonna feel
fine you'll be fine what do you think
they ate a whole pizza in Italy I sit
down with a knife and fork and eat the
pizza they eat a whole pizza Neapolitan
pizza because it's so well proofed and
you know made digestible so there's a
lot to learn you know I love pizza I'll
get to have a man on the move come on
the problem I have here is you're a man
on the move and you know I'm gonna go in
the guys that come up to me I got told
him what I want he has to write it down
put it on a note then the pizza guy puts
it in the oven but I go to my table he
brings me the pizza I can't do that you
want to come back in the kitchen cooking
no I want that guy how do I give the
money to - give me the [ __ ] slice
once and for all giving this way well
I'm talking to him he's going what do
you want - cheese he's throwing him in
and he swung it to the guy next me what
do you want - cheese well you want with
those two cheese I want a large coke and
some [ __ ] that's all gentlemen pop up
about he rings you up he takes you
[ __ ] this shot rings this [ __ ] guy
he's on a timer
he's on a timer in his mind listen he
looks at yours he pushes it over pushes
this one to the side closes the
everything knows everything about those
Knicks yeah and then you tell them they
suck dick they cost $1 anything turns
around and gives you two [ __ ] slices
yeah but I would go to a place in
Hollywood where they have a give it to
the [ __ ] Mexican then the Mexican had
to run it back for the other man and
then go back to Tijuana yeah and then
they'd [ __ ] walk it back that's not a
slice a slice is on the move if I come
to buy a pizza yeah then I sit down when
I come in here for a slice get two
[ __ ] plastic dishes put together the
slice and fold and just give it to me I
put in a bag if you put in the bag
a tree died because you put in a bag one
of the chances this piece of making it
home I'm 300 [ __ ] pounds of this
[ __ ] slice making at home why you
give me a bucking bag boy I don't need
it I don't need it I'm gonna eat it
right now that's right it's like sushi
leave the damn dilution IGP buyer I can
I take this home listen he's on the
bathroom there's Windex just drink that
cuz that's what happens and you bring
sushi home it's made he's right [ __ ]
there to say and I'm not saying a good
[ __ ] like if I go to a pizza place if
I come in and he's making a fresh pizza
but there's a pie and it's got a fly on
it and it's kind of petrified I'm going
to look at that give me two of those cuz
I want the one big net I want the one
that Kallang you it over yeah oh yeah
that's the slice that's delicious yeah
but the one that Kellogg elated
overnight and rather [ __ ] is on fire oh
yeah comes together you let me buy only
pizza if I don't see an Italian that's
true I'm very prejudiced affection for
that don't mind listen if you're ever I
love hummus and baba okay I will never
go in there and eat if you're Cuban
stick the Cuban food don't let me see
you [ __ ] making pizza well
authenticity means it means a lot yeah I
want I don't care if you pick your nose
or scratch ass I eat the slice if
there's a hair in it
god bless y'all hey kid God knows give
me another one God knows what's in your
system what we talked about it with
pizza pizza no you don't eat unless
there's an Italian but I I just
something I used to eat there's only one
guy broke the exception when I was a kid
there was a guy named Nick mixed pizza
he was a Greek degenerate gambler Oh
somebody's come on wrong by Greeks right
this I thought this was in the 70s he
was the only Greek allowed in the
Fayette County that's when this is the
70s but Greek Italian to come busy and
go your names ends with an S yeah
sorry laughs - this is not happening
noble next time you saw a slice we light
the place on fire yeah we have a navy oh
yeah unless you make a partner in
Italian so be Nick's and Jose
like people would not go to your feeds
of life what's the place we saw in a way
over here was a Middle Eastern and pizza
yeah no I don't go Italian right I got
nothing just a Beatle but stick to what
you don't make the kibbeh maybe you know
make a flag that's something that's
indigenous you make a flag
no no I want you to get away with this
last time at the Irish last name but my
mother's name is Jen no I could tell
they're gonna help the king in yet but
even my brother when I went home because
I went to the sushi place from the bay
and I asked him about Japan and they
said they didn't know nothing about
Japan and there were Koreans and
everyone back again like okay I'm not
the only one that feels this way but hey
so Lily Nick was the character that Nick
would call me aspect of my face he
called everybody by that and there was a
kid who would buy a slice there and
would go across the street to get an
iced tea cuz it was a nickel cheaper and
Nick would run out and go you [ __ ]
Jew Sicilian by the window so we called
it the Sicilian International Airport
because all the Flies would come in and
land that was the take-off and runway
yeah that's what they were load up you
could see the other flies load the guns
they're landing and there was a fan
right by it
so the flies had to get off the PI and
go through the fan will not get mad Ted
chopped up three drove Nick drove a hard
bargain
yeah if you will fly you just weren't
gonna walk and then eat his pizza but he
kept the Sicilian by the window and I'll
always go Nick come on give me half
price has been fly [ __ ] on there all
day hey [ __ ] you you [ __ ] check one
night I went in there with quaaludes he
stopped calling me spring I was in there
she fed him I was in there with two
quaaludes and my buddy threw a whole
thing of crushed red pepper at machines
previously we had a beam you come who
many he's my buddy had a beetle qualify
as all the Khomeini and my but it's like
I'm [ __ ] Italian all right stop with
that Ayatollah and he threw a [ __ ]
red oh we were kid we were savages with
Nick and I remember I was like I'd puke
all over my shirt and every time he saw
me after that it was 1982 so you called
me Belushi you're going to die like
Belushi I used to sell more of a hot
gold
can we rob gold I would sell to him he
look at it and they look at me you sure
this is gold speak yes it is
he looking at 14 got it I give you $50
but he would take it and he put in an
apron right behind the bathroom but I
would wait till he stock up and then I'd
ask him to use the bathroom like steal
the jewelry - I'm glad wait a week and
come back Nick
resale and he look at me and look at the
ring is saying I know this ring that's
that's recycling oh my god he's
fortunate he will clear with such a
degenerate gambler he would just close
like if there was a race at the
Meadowlands in the afternoon close be
back from one house he gotta go and he
would come right back now when I went to
shoot the soprano we were in New York we
shot in Bay Ridge Brooklyn and the guys
were like we're going to his pizza place
this afternoon but before we could go
the father still runs it it's like the
best pizza in Brooklyn it's been there
for us a hundred years and I find he is
all there and he makes his own pizza
does not let his sons touch the pizza he
makes the pizza the son walks the slice
right out or he will walk the pizza out
from the kitchen the sisters at the
counter and Dom DeMarco is still
standing there it takes so long to get a
slice you can wake two three what hours
I heard that there's times yes take a
map oh yes he's so old oh he's got to be
in this for 95 95 yeah so you'll go then
the thing says close and you'll see his
two little feet he just decides to take
a little back go there though that's
history that's people I know we were
gonna go but they said it's closed we
only had an hour for lunch it was a half
yes I'm already up there so like I was
making the trek from Manhattan to
Brooklyn which is no big deal we were
shooting the movie they were like let's
go to the pizza tomorrow for me and then
a guy called bagless it's closed we were
on the set at 7:00 in the morning we had
a 1 a 2 o'clock lunch
how cool is doing Sopranos the movie
yeah the move
was David Chase that's cool David chase
I've something out of this world
yeah I'm goal his birthday party thanks
what are you really yeah they invited me
this birthday party like it's a Haiti at
the 72nd a very cool you play the bass
but you love music I saw some well you
did something with prints you yeah you
get some arranged on sufferance and
whatnot you know it's really weird when
you walk into the room and I've never
thought I mean it might in the back of
my mind for me to survive as a man I
have to think him in my head I got the
biggest dick in the room you know when I
was as soon as he stood next to me I
knew his dick was 2 feet bigger than
mine gondol Feeny no I didn't do this a
problem for Gandolfini the prequel movie
I guess I just shot it in May in April
in June but when you're with David Chase
you know that's what comedy is like you
strive that hopefully in 50 years you'll
get to that point you know musically
like I know if I love you been paying
the bass for 47 years old 47 years think
about it when you're playing the bass on
your 60th anniversary I can basically
turn the lights off strap the bass
behind your leg behind your neck and you
can play it like it's that's what he is
with yeah that's where he's at
you don't know that about him until
you're around and then you watch the
series again and you go why wasn't just
me I'm pushing for the line he's not
giving you that line he's making you
watch the visual to make it funny he's
making you working he's making you work
last week I went home this night I go
home like I'm alright
and I throw on HBO to go and plug this
of problems there was an episode last
week when juniors at the hospital mmm
and he sees the chick the old lady from
the neighborhood Chickie's wife and he
walks up but he's supposed to sit in the
chair inglis I'm not sitting in the
chair I'm standing oh of course yes
there's also some big black guy came up
he goes mr. soprano
he goes like this in his voice he could
have said a thousand
things but David chase throw the humor
in him just looking at the black guy
looking at the girl taking two steps
back and just sitting down and going
like in his mind he told you what the
[ __ ] balls on this young yeah tell
the biggest yeah that's right what do
you want to tell you that you know yeah
that's it unfold that's what we've
forgotten in the night in the 2000 we've
forgotten your mind filling in blanks
for movies we give you everything with a
movie now when you watch The Exorcist
[ __ ] with your mind it lets your mind
work the directors used to make your
mind work now you got a camera you're a
director yeah such trouble of director
does it's the same thing in music it's
the same right so when when you get
around I can't imagine being around
inspect the clues now who played
Inspector Clouseau lyric wit Peter
Sellers yeah he's dead while he was
shooting the Pink Panther
if you weren't there taking notes you
know when I see planes trains and
automobiles I don't John Candy stole the
movie but if I'm a comedian standpoint
it was Steve Martin because he had to
learn how to tame himself down to let
this guy run you're not gonna how funny
was Steve so not that all this guy could
out funny you in a heartbeat but he took
his calmly and showed it to you in a
different way hey you know what I'm in
the mood to watch lately
it's a tomorrow night my Blue Heaven I
haven't seen in a long time you want my
mom when my mama said we watch that
movie how great is that it's pretty I
mean it was I never heard of it buddy
right remember you married her yeah I
probably didn't get a lot of notoriety
did it I don't know what year it came
out but it was just it just didn't do it
yeah to me those are comedy masterpieces
when I saw Eddie Murphy delirious I knew
that was a come when I saw Dice Clay
special I loved science special you know
it's it's really weird to be around
those guys like it is if when Emerson
Palmer walked in yeah or you know when
uh what would happen with BB King walks
and they look scene he goes 200a yeah
and you're standing on
- today I'm about to [ __ ] [ __ ] my
pants and puke
this is biggie BB King in the [ __ ]
room ya know so you're sitting with no
ya like what you said you know jack
white whatever you're just happy to
[ __ ] see these people yeah it's I
never liked Roger Waters I know it's
[ __ ] ego over power we spoke about ego
and one that I like ego I don't I don't
love it an ego I don't care what it has
everybody work a [ __ ] he going under
the prick that broke up cuz he broke up
Pink Floyd another [ __ ] broke up the
police that phone sting I said that ego
over [ __ ] you know all those egos
have always [ __ ] killed me the egos
will screw up everything then but now
with music it doesn't seem like the
Eagles are there no more these people
are just happy to be up there whether
it's Pat whether it's Lennon Skynyrd
whether it's you know I speak to Rudy a
lot Rudy goes on the road with loving
spoonful one of those really this Funk
Railroad over and funk yeah one of those
yes cool you know last year was the band
from Seattle not Soundgarden that
Nirvana not the other one the other one
who's the other one from ah I will let
you close to you I will help you see it
through there when I silent lucidity
doesn't domed or alter Honorable about
silent lucidity I forget the name of the
band he played with them for a couple
tours you know he's a busy guy
is he really it's gotta be 6770 I guess
we're all getting older and he's got a
radio show the music you know so me and
Shire Queens Queens right
oh he's like yeah I know he was on road
with Queens right he does the it's
amazing how you're not that distant
anymore as a musician when you and I
were growing up Led Zeppelin was a year
away they were upon the way we live in a
world today where if we try hard enough
Jimmy Page just my
I see you back on Twitter you never know
or Dave Gilmour just wait and see you
back on Twitter or you know or Joey Diaz
or Joey be is Mick where did I meet you
at church Church yeah my daughter it was
a real pleasure meeting you likes my
pleasure having you on thank you very
much Hamish ooh I was gonna meet a
friend the last two weeks
yeah we're gonna meet in the middle of
Ventura and Studio City
so I decided let's just meet at Thousand
Oaks at Parma she called today and I
don't know he's coming down today so I
have to meet you next week so I'll go to
Parma and I'll give my review and [ __ ]
please do they go in there with a
disguise on so nobody knows okay boss
he'll probably be there I'll be gone he
won't even recognize me you gotta see
the disguises that come up with no ranch
it's in Thousand Oaks and I dress up as
a nun you won't even know it's me a fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] is there any other kind
though where do these guys find your
brother we are at seven nine six East
Thousand Oaks Boulevard and what's your
website is your website is Parma
pizzeria Napoletana
no you're [ __ ] well on my website
yeah it's Mick my hand icon in the end
got pictures on there you there's
pictures on everything there's a little
taste of music here and there stuff and
you still do your music also yeah I do I
don't do as much as I used to because
even the television business has become
diluted with a bunch of people that'll
give the music away for free I can't see
doing that you know I think people
should be paid for their art do you have
a stage at the pizza place no we do not
it's a very small pizza place I have how
the [ __ ] don't you that was the yeah
because we're out of our minds we
started off real small but just a little
stay a little stage you got into an open
mic we've had full bands in there you
know oh yeah oh yeah we've had full
bands in there the grand opening and the
best drummers in the world live in
Thousand Oaks I mean they're all the
studio guys have played on millions of
records and they all come in you know
and they'll play so we don't do it often
but I want to do a little bit more of
that like Sunday afternoon open up the
front doors bring a band in who cares if
it's too loud
you know just the ticket it's a ticket
the ticket
[ __ ] it's a it's a voice and I will see
you if I don't see you at the pond
farmer
I will see your tallbird 19th at Saban
Saban yeah leader
yes getting ready for Pat Benatar I have
my [ __ ] wish list tired song she
needs to play as a lot of stop that
chill here a bunch there's a song she
put on the one out and me and my buddy
were going through a lot at this time he
was [ __ ] he's a rich kid but he was
still going through hell and I was gone
it was 83 it was getting nervous
mm-hmm and it's called silent part of it
oh yeah and I'm gonna forget
I forgot all about that song the one day
I was on the [ __ ] plane I had like
two edibles in me and like dude salutes
in me and I'm going through what I see
get nervous I go let me put it on I put
on you know calling for a stranger in
the night all that [ __ ] what silent
partner came uh the beginning the
synthesizer that first two chords had to
rip my earphones off it had taken me
right back into that car we used to
drive up and down we were both suicidal
I mean we had nothing going on with our
lives were twenty years old you're
living off this together was Pat Benatar
is that right yeah that acid scene Black
Sabbath example because the only thing
that kept us living was that Led
Zeppelin was gonna make it yesterday
yesterday or the day before was the 40th
anniversary of Led Zeppelin at that
festival what's the big fast way to do
every year
Coachella there's no gay chela back then
Coachella over in England where the
start opened up for a skin it opened up
for the stones the stones didn't have a
choice Skynyrd [ __ ] him blew him off
the table they told the told skin and
not to walk on the tongue and skin it
when I Dan walked on the tongue it drew
the stones off they came out with
Bowie's smoking cigarettes but that was
Lynyrd Skynyrd the Edinburgh Owen and
Beru
so it's yesterday two days ago was the
40th anniversary of this way Edinburgh
if you will look at that video we in the
podcast you have to see Jimmy Page's
heroin addiction they
was nothing - they would dress nicely
but he was just shirt - scratching and
she know he was just shirt and you could
see the bones and sweat he does Achilles
last stand well yesterday was the 40th
anniversary so now the chitter-chatter
was starting if they were going to do
the states they were I forget one bar
Mumbai it's gonna be the 40th
anniversary next and the next
it's gotta be the next month the piers
been gone a long time 79 it's gotta be
the next two months cuz I still remember
being at a restaurant and moff and Joe's
eating the [ __ ] egg on egg on Jersey
style eggs and we added our cheese nice
and they said we'll have an announcement
Saturday about a big man in those days
you didn't might tickets you and a man
on a money order and they tell you if
you got there's no taykitty master or
anything no and [ __ ] September 25th
of 80 boy was I wrong
Rick it was a real pleasure thanks you
too man any time you want to thank very
much the [ __ ] pizza parlor or the
tour or a new album you know a single
I'm sure we'll hang it well or no
whatever you want to do we're here for
you all right thank you thank you very
much and now for a word from our
sponsors all right I want to thank my
man Mick my hand I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want thank you [ __ ] for always
listening to having our back
it's a beautiful [ __ ] week kids
are back to school but first let me talk
to you about a few things
the church is sponsored by upstart most
of us find out the hard way but getting
into debt is real easy getting out of
debt that's a complete different story
that's hard especially if your FICO
score isn't great thankfully now there's
upstart calm a revolutionary lending
platform that knows you're more than
just a credit score you're upstart
interest rate is based on your education
and job history
not your credit score upstart doesn't
care about the bills you didn't pay five
years ago they care about the person you
are now
today and they give you a rate based on
that
they make it fast simple and easy to
check your rate in just a few minutes
without affecting your credit score the
best part once the loan is approved most
people get their funds the very next
business day the next day over 200
thousand people have used up start to
pay off credit cards student loans fund
their weddings or make a large purchase
with up start you can free yourself from
the burden of iron since credit card
debt by consolidating everything into
one monthly payment you cannot beat that
you understand me you take everything
you own
put it down to 1 now you know where you
stand and that's what upstart will do to
you
so do me a favor will do for you so do
me a favor see why I'm starting is
ranked number one in the category with
over 300 businesses on Trustpilot Harry
the upstart comm slash Church CH you are
CH to find out how low your up start
rate is checking your rate only takes a
few minutes and it won't affect your
credit that's upstart com slash Church
the church is also brought to you by my
favorite CBD lion calm listen they may
CBD products from start to finish
CBD lions got you covered whether you
want a vape well cartridge or shadow if
you're not into smoke and listen like I
said in the beginning the gummies are
fantastic the raspberry the strawberry
in the orange don't put you in a
different [ __ ] orbit you're not gonna
get high off him this is pure CBD you
follow me their products are clean and
they aren't like the face that you see
with all the [ __ ] up advertising and
the [ __ ] liquor stores and all that
[ __ ] this is CBD the way it's
supposed to be last night
two nights ago I went to the Comedy
Store on Saturday and I went home and I
took the purple bar over five thousand
milligrams and I put it under my tongue
I got home at 10:30 do you know at 11:15
I cannot keep my [ __ ] eyes open I was
up at 5:00 during the morning on the
Lord's Day walking around I take a
[ __ ] nap anyway go to CBD line.com
and check out their third-party test
results
yourself the church family gets 20% off
and check out me personally whatever the
cream for your knee elbow you shoulder
the tension you're tip-top Magoo don't
forget about the gummies so go to CBD
line that time right now and press in
Church your check out and get 20% off
your order
I want to thank upstart I want to thank
CBB lion calm but most importantly I
want to thank you savages for always
having my back go to Joey Diaz dotnet
for tour dates t-shirts cups whatever
the [ __ ] you need alright that's it and
that's that
we'll see you [ __ ] Wednesday
tip top Magoo I love you Lee
kick this [ __ ] meal